the Joe Rogan experience but that lady
that new press secretary she's he sent
me a video - she's a gangster
have you seen I've never seen someone
more prepared for a question in your
life Jamie small point on that not the
big point but small point she was so
prepared yes
that's why I'm saying what she's
supposed to be prepared that's I said
you've never seen someone know prepare
for that there very question yes yes
they're prepared and you know why
they're prepared cuz you're trying to
play gotcha yeah she played gotcha with
them she checkmated this she came in
there with that [ __ ] Elon Musk
flamethrower like Leonardo DiCaprio
you're on your own no no no I was saying
I almost was saying that it almost seems
like she was working with that reporter
to say hey feed me this so I can [ __ ] on
everybody now like I got that was
happened that guy was yelling he was
like no you were ready for this why do
you just see self we've served her up a
softball so she could [ __ ] fire off
the machine no I don't know that's not
what he did it all like I try to play
gotcha with her do you want to take your
word back because she said that Trump is
not gonna let the coronavirus come into
the country and what she's saying the
reason why they're shutting down of
travel from Asia is because they're
worried about the coronavirus coming to
the country and trump's not gonna let
that happen they they tried to take what
she said and and take it out of context
or framing make you look bad while she
was saying that Trump is not gonna let
the country get infected by the
coronavirus what she's trying to say is
it she's not gonna have free travel
where people have coronavirus because
it's gonna bring the virus in not that
it's the only way the virus is gonna get
here the virus got here anyway that came
with the fire are you gonna take that
first of all it's a douchey question
like all this was a kind of douche bags
in the first place they're trying so
hard to have these moments where they
they [ __ ] play got yeah but when did
when did these journalists quit being
journalists and become like [ __ ]
trolls off reddit like some of their
questions to Trump that's why Trump goes
so hard in the paint on them I know but
he goes too hard the property cares too
much too much cares too much about what
they think a lion should not be so
concerned
about the opinion of sheep correct
that's each it's not it's not becoming
of someone who's in such a powerful
position you're the president dude yeah
that guy's a [ __ ] rider for the way
she handles it though
oh my god she just dropped a photo
assessing it was ex Wildey coyote with
the TNT she's like you ready you want to
do it now
Stu yeah and then she had a big smile
and walked off as they're trying to say
and he's like you prepared for the sweat
thank you have a good day oh gee you
think she prepared for it with all those
stats that she read right in front of
you dude they need to hire your boy Elon
Musk to get on that first video babbling
the first thing I have didn't have the
video links I'm looking I read i
retweeted it he's holding on to it to us
[Laughter]
no one online thinks you guys are
playing people online I love Jamie
Vernon and we're just playing however I
do know that he's on the wrong side oh
he's on the side of the bad guys that'd
be flood for you Jane almost let me go
to the fight companion
oh here it is right here play this hold
on full full page and make it loud
President Trump will not allow the
coronavirus
come to this country given what has
happened since then obviously would you
like to take that back
well first let me know what I was asked
a question on Fox Business about
presidents travel restrictions I noted
what was the intent behind those travel
restrictions which is we will not see
the coronavirus come here
we will not see terrorism come here
referring to an earlier set of travel
restrictions I guess I would turn the
question back on the media and ask
similar questions does Vox want to take
back that they proclaim that the
coronavirus would not be a deadly
pandemic does the Washington Post want
to take back that they told Americans to
get a grip the flu is bigger than the
coronavirus which is the Washington Post
likewise we take back that our brains
are causing us to exaggerate the threats
of the coronavirus does the New York
Times want to take back that fear of the
virus may be expressed spreading faster
than the virus itself does NPR want to
take back that the flu was a much bigger
threat than the corona virus and finally
once again the Washington Post would
they like to take back but the
government should not respond
aggressively to the corona virus I'll
leave you with those questions but maybe
you'll have some answers drink that [ __ ]
in Jamie he drink it in you you were
prepared for that oh yeah like you
practice [ __ ] question imagine you
have one opportunity to ask her a
question and that's what you ask her
this but then you get let you the [ __ ]
and then everyone's like that's crazy
yeah you got served
young [ __ ] up he has served I want
Dana Lee Jaime's asking a question I'm
throwing it out there you guys can say
that's not it but I'm just asking a
question
now he's a [ __ ] you could see he was
doing like that that was a kunti
question I don't know if he's cut maybe
a really nice guy you look at his face
though that's his job his job is God try
to get attention and get some gotcha so
he played gotcha and he got caught back
down
[Applause]